and we are not defending some abstract
ideal but the first principle of a
peaceful world which is that large and
powerful countries cannot be allowed to
dismember their neighbors and if this
was ever permitted then no Nation
anywhere would be safe
therefore our goal must be for our
Ukrainian friends to win by which I mean
that Ukraine must have the strength to
finish this war on the terms the
president zielinski has described
and when Putin claimed that by invading
his neighbor he would force NATO away
from Russia he could not have been
proved more spectacularly wrong because
the single most welcome outcome of the
Madrid Summit was the alliance's
agreement to admit Finland and sweep and
I hope I speak for the whole house when
I say that Britain will be proud to
stand alongside these fellow democracies
and reaffirm our unshakable pledge to
come to their aid and defend them if
ever necessary just as they would for us
we were glad to smooth their path into
NATO by giving both Nations the security
assurances they needed to apply for
membership and when I met prime minister
Anderson of Sweden and president ninisto
of Finland last Wednesday I told them I
was certain that NATO would be stronger
and safer for their accession
before Putin's Onslaught both countries
had prized their neutrality even through
all the crises of the Cold War and it's
a measure of how seriously they take
today's threat that opinion in Sweden
and Finland has been transformed and it
speaks volumes about Putin's Folly that
one permanent consequences of his
consequence of his attack on Ukraine
will be a doubling of the length of
NATO's border with Russia if anyone
needed proof that NATO is purely
defensive the fact that two
quintessentially Peaceable countries
should have chosen to join demonstrates
the true nature of our alliance
and now is the time to intensify our
help for Ukraine because Putin's donbass
offensive is slowing down and his
overstretched army is suffering
suffering heavy casualties and Ukraine's
success in forcing the Russians off
Snake Island by sheer weight of
Firepower shows how difficult The
Invader will find it to hold the
territory he has overrun
we need to equip our friends now to take
advantage of the moment when Putin will
have to pause and regroup
so NATO will supply Ukraine with another
billion pounds of military aid including
air defenses drones and electronic
warfare equipment
bringing our total military
humanitarian and economic support since
the 24th of February to nearly 4 billion
pounds
and to guarantee the security of our
allies
on the Eastern flank NATO agreed in
Madrid to bolster its high Readiness
forces and we in the UK will offer even
more British forces to the alliance
including almost all of our surface
Fleet
we have already doubled our deployment
in Estonia and we will upgrade our
national headquarters to be led by a
brigadier and help our Estonian friends
to establish their own divisional
headquarters
if you follow the trajectory trajectory
of our programs to modernize our Armed
Forces Mr Speaker you will draw The
Logical conclusion that the UK will
likely be spending 2.5 percent of GDP on
defense by the end of this decade
at the G7 Summit the first full day of
talks coincided with a Russian missile
destroying a Ukrainian Shopping Center
killing at least 18 people
this barbaric attack on an obviously
civilian Target strengthened the resolve
of my fellow leaders to provide Ukraine
with more financial humanitarian
military and diplomatic backing for and
I quote the communicate again as long as
it takes
exactly the terms later echoed by NATO
the G7 has pledged nearly 30 billion
dollars of financial support for Ukraine
this year and we will tighten our
sanctions on Russia
and the UK will join America Japan and
Canada to ban the import of Russian gold
which previously raised more export
revenues than anything else except
hydrocarbons
the G7 will devise more options for
ensuring that nearly 25 million tons of
grain trapped inside Ukraine by Putin's
blockade reaches the countries that rely
on these supplies
just as the world economy was recovering
from the pandemic Putin's War has caused
a surge in global food and energy prices
raising the cost of living everywhere
including here at home
the G7 agreed
and I quote to take immediate action to
secure energy Supply and reduce price
surges including by exploring additional
measures such as price caps
and we will help our partners in the
developing world to meet their climate
targets and transform millions of lives
by constructing new infrastructure
according to the highest standards of
transparency and Environmental
Protection
through our partnership for Global
infrastructure and investment an idea
launched by the UK at the carbus bay
Summit last year
we will mobilize up to 600 billion
dollars of public and private investment
over the next five years
many beneficiary Nations will be members
of the Commonwealth and I was very
pleased to attend The Summit in Kigali
of this unique Association of 56 States
encompassing a third of humanity
more countries are eager to join and we
are pleased to welcome two new members
in Gabon and Togo
it's an amazing fact that our familiar
legal and administrative systems
combined with the English language knock
21 off the cost of trade between
Commonwealth members
and it's because the Commonwealth unites
that Advantage with some of the fastest
growing markets in the world that we're
using that the sovereignty that the UK
has regained to sign free trade or
economic partnership agreements with as
many commonwealth countries as possible
so far we've done 33 including Australia
and New Zealand and we're aiming for
India by Diwali in October
but it's true Mr Speaker that not every
member of the Commonwealth sees Putin's
aggression
as we do or exactly as we do and it was
vital to have the opportunity to counter
the myths and to point out that food
prices are rising because Putin has
blockaded one of the world's biggest
food producers and if large countries
are free to destroy their neighbors then
no Commonwealth member however distant
from Ukraine would be genuinely secure
the fact that in a week the UK was able
to deal on friendly terms with scores of
countries in three organizations shows
the extraordinary diplomatic assets our
country possesses and as we stand up for
what is right in Ukraine
and Advance the values and interests of
the British people I commend this
statement to that
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to thank
the Prime Minister for advanced copy of
his statement and to welcome him back to
these chores they say that absence makes
the heart grow fonder so I wish him the
best of luck in seeing if that works as
a party management strategy
[Laughter]
it's been 131 days since Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine
131 days of War at the heart of our
continent
131 days of Putin trying to cower his
neighbors
131 days of Brave Ukrainian resistance
I've always said that this house and
Britain's allies must put aside our
differences in other areas and show
unity in our opposition to Putin's
aggression
and we have driven by the inspiration
provided by the people of Ukraine and
the leadership and courage of president
zielinski
conflict reaches its sixth month
and drags on in eastern Ukraine it's
important that we don't think our job is
done
Putin would like nothing better
than for us to lose our Focus for the
grip of sanctions to weaken for military
aid to Ukraine to dry up or for cracks
to appear in the unity of Putin's
opponents
so I welcome the progress made at the
NATO Summit last week
and congratulate our good friends in
Finland and Sweden for their formal
invitation to join the NATO alliance
course Ukraine on securing their
candidate status to join the European
Union
I hope these processes can be concluded
as quickly as possible to send a clear
message to Putin that his War has
permanently changed the European
landscape
but not in the way that he planned
I also welcome the commitment to
strengthen our Collective deterrent
capabilities
I've seen firsthand how British
Personnel are working with other NATO
forces to ensure the collective Shield
that's protected us for three quarters
of a century remains as strong as ever
so I welcome the agreement on the new
NATO force model ensuring over 300 000
conventional troops will be at high
Readiness across Europe
can I ask the Prime Minister how this
agreement will affect British military
planning and if he believes our extra
commitments can be met given his cuts to
UK troop numbers
the commitment made at the G7 of further
financial support for Ukraine is also
welcome
as our plans to help you train with
post-war reconstruction through an
International Conference
Mr Speaker there could be no clearer
case that Aid spending makes Britain
more secure and prevents the need for
military spending in the future which
demonstrates the Folly in reducing our
Aid commitments at a time of global
instability
yeah I'm pleased that Unity was on
display at both the NATO Summit and the
G7 Summit
but I am concerned about current Unity
within the Commonwealth
the Commonwealth is a valuable and
important Institution for this country
it isn't just a symbol of our past
it's important for our future providing
us with influence in all parts of the
world
but in recent years there have been
serious signs of strain
when many major commonwealth countries
abstained that the UN over Russia's
invasion of Ukraine the summit should
have been an opportunity to widen
diplomatic Coalition against Putin
instead the Prime Minister waged a
divisive campaign against the
Commonwealth leadership that indeed up
in a humiliating diplomatic failure only
illustrating his embarrassing lack of
influence
instead of investing in Aid that
strengthens the alliance he's cut it
instead of upholding the rule of law
that should Define the Commonwealth he
reneges on treaties that he signed
undermining Britain's moral and
political credibility when we need our
word to carry Trust
my fear is simple the vacuum We Leave
Behind will be quickly filled not by
those who share our values but by those
who seek to destroy them we cannot let
that happen in Ukraine we cannot let
that happen anywhere thank you Mr
Speaker prime minister well I'm Mr
Speaker I thank the right honorable
gentleman for the uh terms in which it
broadly speaking he has addressed the uh
the UK's recent diplomatic activity just
a couple of points to come back on he
talks about the uh the UK breaking
International treaties misters uh Mr
Speaker actually uh that is I don't know
whether what he's talking about there
but he's talking about what we're doing
in respect of the Northern Ireland
protocol uh then that is not what is
happening uh Mr Speaker we believe that
Our obligation our prior obligation
which I would have thought he supported
is to the balance of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement that's what was
important and actually you know he talks
about uh the UK's diplom ability to win
people over it was very striking Mr
Speaker in uh the conversations I had
with leaders from around the world uh
how uh how few of them if any raised the
issue uh Mr Speaker of the Northern
Ireland protocol and how uh how much uh
Mr Speaker people want to see common
sense and no new barriers to trade what
the UK is doing is trying to reduce
pointless barriers to trade and uh you
would have thought Mr Speaker that he he
would uh support that and on the on his
points about uh the UK's contribution to
Nato and to the new force model and
whether that is sustainable I really
suggest Mr Speaker that members opposite
should talk to the NATO Secretary
General again stoltenberg about what the
UK is is producing and what the UK is
committing it is colossal we are the
second biggest contributor to Nato where
the second biggest contributor overall
to support for the ukrainians uh Mr
Speaker a 2.3 billion in military
assistance alone and what we're also
doing Mr Speaker is making sure that our
armed forces are provided for the future
uh with 24 billion pounds in this
spending review the biggest uplift in
defense spending since the Cold War
defense spending now running at 2.3
percent of our national GDP above the 2
Target Mr Speaker that is felt around
the room in NATO people know what the UK
is contributing and they are they are
extremely grateful what the UK also
contributes to Nato under the new force
model we will contribute uh virtually
all our Naval forces Mr Speaker but we
also as he knows we are the only country
to contribute our strategic independent
nuclear deterrent to Nato and I still
find it a sad reflection on the party
opposite that at this critical Time When
Vladimir Putin is very very sadly using
the language of nuclear blackmail we are
in a situation which is the principal
party what position in this country
still has eight members on its front
bench who voted to discard our
independent nuclear but Mr Speaker
including including the shadow foreign
secretary so apart from that Mr Speaker
I welcome the terms in which the right
honorable gentleman uh has responded
[Music]
Mr Speaker could I know that's welcome
the prime minister's statement could I
ask the Prime Minister was there General
agreement at all three summits that our
fragile rules-based order is under
threat and strategically we've entered a
profound era of geopolitical change
could I commend the prime minister's
efforts in Ukraine it's the same other
NATO countries haven't lent as much as
we've done but could I commend or
encourage the prime minister to go
further and to secure a UN General
Assembly resolution to create a
humanitarian Safe Haven around that
critical Port of Odessa so there's vital
grain exports can not only reach Europe
but also Africa and prevent famine there
prime minister I I thank my right
tolerable friend for his point
particularly about green exports and as
he knows the work is being led by the by
the U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez uh the UK is doing a huge
amount to uh support and Mr Speaker but
as I've told the house before uh we may
have to prepare for a solution that does
not depend upon Russian uh consent
because that may not be forthcoming SMP
leader in Blackford thank you Mr Speaker
and can I thank the Prime Minister for
Advance copy of your statement and
welcome them back from his travels
around Africa and Europe and it's
perhaps worth reiterating Mr Speaker
that all of us in his house reiterate
our support for president zwinski for
Ukraine and their struggle against the
war criminal Putin Mr Speaker the scale
and the depth of the challenge facing
our Global Community is self-evident war
in Europe the return of sorting
inflation Rising interest rates and the
cost of living crisis that is punishing
people in the pocket we're not just
faced with one crisis this is an
accumulation of Crisis that Leeds
deserves and demands a collective
response we know that at moments like
this solutions can only come from a
coordinated effort previous efforts
during the 2007 financial crisis and the
coordination during covid demonstrate
just that right across the world and
none of us should be in any doubt the
crisis we are now in it's a very bitter
severe and Steep and deep as anything
that we face in the time of the
financial crisis but Mr Speaker so far
and I regret to say this that the
collective effort that sense of urgency
has been badly lacking particularly from
organizations like the G7 the response
has been far too slow and far too small
prime minister it is obvious that the G7
outcomes are nowhere near enough to
combat the cost of living crisis that we
now face so when can the public expect
some leadership and some action when
will we see a coherent coordinated
incredible plan to increase energy
Supply cap prices and drive investment
to the global economy before recession
becomes inevitable or does the plan
really to delay until the winter when
things will only get worse leadership
now in responding to supply shots will
allow us to fight inflation or a failure
to take appropriate action exposes all
of us to longer lasting inflationary
risks
on Ukraine can the Prime Minister
perhaps go a little bit further and give
us a an Outlook as to what we will do to
make sure that we can get grain out of
Ukrainian ports
400 million people worldwide rely on
Ukrainian Food Supplies this is now not
just about stopping War it's about
stopping famine too and finally I'm sure
the Prime Minister will agree that of
all these Global efforts we'll only
begin and will only work if there is
trust between global leaders can the
Prime Minister therefore explain that in
this moment of many crisis how exactly
breaking international law and
threatening to start a trade war with
our neighbors helps anyone Minister
uh yeah well thank you Mr Speaker
actually I think that he should look at
more carefully at what the uh the G7 uh
produced in terms of the uh the plan to
cap prices for uh for oil and gas and
particularly to try to stop Putin
profiteering as he currently is from his
uh from his illegal War there is a plan
it's not I won't pretend it's going to
be easy but we're doing as much as as we
can and we're certainly uh taking a lot
of other action for instance to help
countries around the world with access
to to fertilizer that they need and he's
right to raise the issue Mr Speaker of
the 25 billion tons of grain currently
uh held hostage in uh in Odessa uh there
is a plan to get that out it's not easy
but if you look to the numbers we are
gradually getting more grain out of uh
those Ukrainian silos uh back into uh
Europe back into to Africa we will
continue uh to do that as for his final
Point Mr Speaker uh about the UK and uh
a so-called breach of international I
really repeat what I I said to the right
on development uh opposite uh what the
what the countries around the world see
is the UK offering consistent uh
consistent leadership uh in the matter
of standing up uh for the rule of law uh
and standing up against Putin's
aggression and that is I I promise you
that is what has been raised with me in
the last 10 days hello Brooke thank you
Mr Speaker um my congratulate my rotten
friend for the leadership he's shown in
this previous week and welcome
um his commitment to our Royal Navy
forces and being part of NATO
um as my defense security committee on
NATO parliamentary assembly starts its
investigation with the next two years
into the Russian Maritime threat can I
ask my honorable friend does he see the
ongoing support of the royal Navy in the
long term and what conversation can you
have with other NATO allies to increase
their Maritime support to this vital
mission
I want to congratulate him by the way on
his work for the NATO parliamentary
assembly which was uh which was
mentioned to me at the at the summit and
I can tell him that the UK is leading
the uh the NATO alliance in providing
for uh for the a new force model in our
Naval commitment and we're trying to
encourage others to do the same yeah
there's a red band
indeed Mr Speaker further to the
question from November Feast the Prime
Minister will know that time is running
out to get gray to the hundreds of
millions of people who will be facing uh
destitution and hunger as the Secretary
General has warned could he tell us
who is going to provide the security
guarantees to Ukraine because the fear
is if you open a sea Corridor that the
Russians will seek to use it to attack
Odessa and can he confirm that it is to
Turkey that the world is looking to
provide those guarantees so the grain
can get out before the moment is lost
prime minister is completely right the
Turks are absolutely indispensable uh to
to solving this and they can they are
they're doing uh their very best I think
president again for all uh for the
efforts that he is making it does depend
on the Russians agreeing to allow that
grain to get out the UK is offering uh
demining uh facilities we're offering
Insurance facilities for the for the
vessels that will be needed to to get
the grain out uh Mr Speaker but we will
you know if he's right about the the
urgency and we will increasingly have to
look at alternative means of moving that
grain from Ukraine if we cannot use uh
the sea route if you can't use the
Bosphorus
really nervous
before there was a shooting war in
Europe in the 1980s does the Prime
Minister accept that it was right for
this country to spend five percent of
GDP on defense and if he does why does
he think it's adequate for us to spend
only half that percentage by the end of
this decade
prime minister I I thank my right arm
has been very much and he has campaigned
on this issue for for years and I have
to say that I think that we will have to
spend more in uh logically Mr Speaker if
you protract the commitments that we are
making under orcas and uh under the
future combat aircraft system uh we will
be increasing our spending very
considerably what we want to do is to
make sure that other allies are doing
the same and that is the most important
we want to see and that's why Jen
stoltenberg is going to we hope going to
be setting a new Target and allowing the
whole of the alliance to increase their
funding David speaker while the Prime
Minister was talking about British
values at three international Summits he
was whipping concerted MPS to vote to
trash one of our greatest British values
the rule of law
and while the Prime Minister was talking
about increasing defense spending he's
plowing ahead with plans to cut the
British Armed Forces by 10 000 troops
and while the Prime Minister was talking
about the problem of global price Rises
he is raising unfair taxes on millions
of pensioners and families across our
country so Mr Speaker we are facing a
domestic economic crisis a Global
Security crisis and the prime minister
is facing his own political crisis so
can he tell the house what precisely is
his plan to take our country forward
well Mr Speaker I'm very happy to uh
tell the right honorable gentleman that
our plan uh is to help the people of
this country as we are uh with the cost
of living with 1200 pounds coming into
people's uh bank accounts and cities are
asked Mr Speaker uh this month uh across
which we can do because of the sensible
economic steps that we have uh taken in
coming out of the pandemic but then to
build on a stronger uh build a stronger
economy Mr Speaker with reforms to our
planning to our housing to our transport
to our energy networks we will take down
costs for people up and down of the
country Mr Speaker and continue to make
this place the best place to live in and
invest in in the whole of our hemisphere
that's our plan uh for the country and I
I commend it to it
Western purchases of Russian energy are
paying for Putin's War so will he
redouble his efforts to make sure we
invest in more production and output of
oil gas and electricity here to make our
contribution to reducing Western
dependence
speaker yes I think it look I think it's
the UK can be very proud of the way that
we have moved uh Beyond hydrocarbons in
so many areas but we have to recognize
the the limits and the pace uh of what
we've achieved and that we have to be
less neuralgic about using our domestic
hydrocarbons particularly when the
alternative is just to import them from
abroad Chris Brown thank you Mr Speaker
it's
3056 days since Putin started his
illegal invasion of Ukraine and we spent
far too long turning a blind eye to what
was going on there so forgive me if I'm
just a little bit impatient even about
what we have already achieved I want to
see a British industrial strategy to
make sure we're making enough lethal
Weaponry to give to the ukrainians so
that they can win I want to see a major
diplomatic effort to make sure that
Putin isn't going to make further
inroads in Republica serbska and Bosnia
I also want to make sure that we as a
country are still as focused on the
laundering of dirty Russian money
through the city of London as we should
have been 10 years ago
prime minister Mr Speaker as he knows
the UK led the way in Europe in
supplying Weaponry to Ukraine uh the the
end laws were of great importance uh Mr
Speaker and when it comes to uh
sanctions I think the UK has uh again uh
we have a new economic crime Bill coming
in uh that will help us to clamp down
further uh but what we have done already
is is very very considerable and uh the
The Squeeze is being felt uh by Putin
and his economy and we will continue to
apply it and I think that he asked for a
long-term strategy what he got from the
G7 and from NATO was a commitment to
stick the course for as long as it takes
and that's what we're going to do Mark
copper much Mr Speaker when the prime
minister's remarks that the NATO Summit
were reported last week the two and a
half percent uh commitment to spend on
defense appeared to be really quite
solid um his remarks today are less so
so assuming it is a commitment can I
just ask him is it a commitment and
secondly how are we going to pay for it
because you have to have a credible plan
to pay for it are we going to put up
taxes or are we going to reduce
expenditure in other areas to deliver
what is a welcome and important
commitment to the defense of the United
Kingdom prime minister Mr Speaker this
is a a straightforward protraction of a
prediction based on what what we are
currently committed to uh to spending on
under the the orcas uh program or and
under the the fcas program as well with
these are gigantic uh commitments I
think the right thing for the for the UK
they will take us up uh to that
threshold of course it much depends on
the size of of our GDP at the time Mr
Speaker much depends on the growth in
the economy house how we're going to uh
to pay for it I think we're going to pay
for it out of steady and sustained
economic growth as I said to the
gentleman opposite
thank you Mr Speaker the northern Irish
protocol Bill the Legacy and
Reconciliation bill and the Bill of
Rights are all bills which numerous
informed common teachers and cross-party
Committees of this house have said
threatened to breach our International
treaty obligations and I know he
indicated to the leader of the
opposition that some of his
interoperators last week at least had
raised these issues with him and all of
us who've traveled abroad in
parliamentary business recently will
have had these issues raised with us so
can you tell us exactly what concerns
were raised with him over the last week
about his government's disrespect for
for the international rule of law and
human rights and what he's going to do
about it prime minister I I can tell
that The Honorable lady absolutely
Calgary not a single person said that
the UK was in breach of international
law on the contrary what they did say
was that we were helping other world to
stand up against breaches of
internationally but very much Mr Speaker
and prime minister should absolutely be
congratulated on defense spending and
what he's done on it whilst many in his
previous in his position previously have
talked about it actually this is the
biggest increase since the end of the
Cold War but when he confirms me no
directive has been issued from number 10
or the treasury on defense numbers uh on
numbers of personnel and that will
continue to be the case going forward uh
should the situation continue to change
prime minister I I thank you I thank you
very much and I think he as he speaks
wisely on this matter which he knows
very very well and uh we keep the actual
numbers under constant review the most
important thing Mr Speaker is to have
our troops are the best in the world but
they've got also got to have the best
equipment in the world and that's what
we're paying for Liam thank you I was
relieved to see the G7 recognize that
200 million people now face starvation
around the world along with the pledge
to mobilize a hundred billion in IMF
special drawing rights to help alleviate
the crisis last week however the foreign
secretary couldn't tell us
how much the UK has been given in
special drawing rights nor what her
Target was for sharing them back
presumably because it wasn't on
Instagram so can the Prime Minister help
us can he reassure us that all 19
billion of the UK's new special drawing
rights will be shared to help with this
crisis in order to set a good example to
the rest of the world prime minister I
thank him very much and he's absolutely
right to draw attention to the use of
special drawing rights and we are
supportive of of using those for the
benefit of people who are currently
finding things very very tough around
the world
two and a half percent and the prime
minister's hint at this question time
that we may go further than that in the
years to come but would you not agree
with me nonetheless that the last year's
integrated review talked about cutting
conventional forces tanks aircraft and
people put boots on the ground and the
one of the lessons of Ukraine is we must
not do that Willie once again look at
the commitments we have made to cut in
particularly our infantry and think
again about it
prime minister
I I thank you very much and I look at I
I know that uh
my own friend has military experience
himself uh but what we're learning from
our Ukraine what we're learning from uh
Ukraine Mr Speaker is that the vital
importance of uh having uh troops uh
having a military operation that has a
360 degree uh protection and uh has the
best possible equipment now that is a
lesson that I think the Russians are
learning to their costs themselves
thank you Mr Speaker the Prime Minister
will have heard the Deep concern across
both sections of this house particularly
from response to his answer says the
member from Bournemouth to remember from
Leeds about the Grain in Ukraine and the
issue of world hunger and poverty and he
said there in his response that he was
talking about the possibility of seeking
a solution that may not have the consent
of the Russians so for avoidance of
Doubt can he confirm to this house if he
is looking at breaching the Montreal
agreement about larger forces in the
Black Sea please
thank you very much and she's right to
raise that no we're not looking at uh at
that uh that there are alternative uh
solutions that don't involve the
presence of of UK or other uh warships
in the in the Black Sea
um though they might involve a more a a
tougher approach but I think she's what
we're also looking at is the possibility
of using uh the rivers using the Danube
in particular to try to get the uh using
the railways to try to get the grain out
in smaller quantities than we would be
able to do with a giant uh Convoy
through the uh giant Maritime uh Convoy
through the Black Sea so we're looking
at all the possible options uh including
a a
smaller packets of grain coming out that
way yeah
thank you very much Mr Speaker my right
honorable friend stated Ukraine must
have the strength to finish this war in
the way president zielinski described
are we confident that all our allies are
being as involved and supportive as the
UK has been and continues to be for as
long as it takes
prime minister I think the answer to
that is yes Mr Speaker because you know
every time we go to one of these Summits
and we think that the uh the alliance is
friable and that the strength of the
pro-ukrainian Coalition is is weak
actually uh people gravitate towards uh
the center and towards what the UK is
saying basically there's no alternative
Putin isn't offering any kind of deal uh
president zielinski can't do any kind of
land for peace deal there's nothing
there's no other option for us but to
continue to support the ukrainians in
the way that we are and that's why the
unity remains so compelling
Christian Baptist thank you Mr Speaker I
absolutely understand that the sanctions
regime so far has focused on the Russian
Elite travel bans for example uh bands
on export of luxury goods as well as
Russian hydrocarbons that earn them such
so much foreign exchange money but as my
honorable friend from Rhonda said is it
not now the time as this war continues
into the longer term that we look at the
Russian money that is still sloshing
around in the UK and assume that if
somebody has made a large amount of
money in Putin's Russia the chances are
it's dodgy and start to tighten that
domestic sanctions regime prime minister
he's of course right that we will we've
got to keep tightening the news the
whole uh the whole time the economic
crime corporate transparency Bill uh
will help Give us new powers to seize uh
crypto assets new powers over money
laundering but one thing I think that uh
that he would have spotted at the G7 I
think was very uh important was the new
sanctions on Russian gold which I
mentioned in my statement 13.5 billion
pounds worth of sanctions on Russian
gold that will that will hit them
thank you Mr Speaker I welcome what the
Prime Minister said about working with
other countries to reduce the price of
oil and gas that's critical in this
country indeed across the world could he
give the house bit more detail on how
we've been working with other countries
particularly in the Commonwealth on
investing in renewable energy which is
clean safe and secure and reduces our
dependence on hydrocarbons over the
medium term
prime minister
I thank him I thank him I thank you very
much and the uh the answer is that we're
making massive Investments as uh as UK
in uh commonwealth countries but as as
the G7 as I said the partnership for
Global infrastructure and investment is
there specifically uh to help developing
countries countries around the world to
move forwards to make the leap ahead to
Green Technology uh and and take
investment from the UK and not perhaps
from others uh who are busier in getting
them to pay their debts real Handy
thank you Mr Speaker list carefully to
the Prime Minister for awards about the
Commonwealth and the relationship
between independent countries and of
course in 1941 it was then prime
minister Churchill that signed the
Atlantic Charter with the United States
and United States committing both
Britain and United States to um
delivering people's right to choose
their own form of government and
self-government this respect for the
principal equal rights and
self-determination of peoples was
incorporated into the United Nations
Charter in paragraph two of Articles 173
and 76 in light of this can the Prime
Minister set out what mandate he has won
which allows him to breach this un
principle deny Scotland's claim of right
and hold Scotland's democracy hostage
I I thank him very much and I know that
uh uh the the first Minister has asked
for uh for another referendum I just
point out that we had one in in 2014 I
think
right now the prior priorities of the
country should be rebuilding after covid
they should be taking us forward
together as a United Country and that's
what we want to do so Redwood Lee
Ukraine is by far the most important
issue facing us not least in terms of
preventing Mass starvation in Africa one
can't help noticing that unlike all the
other fluff in the newspapers every day
nobody dares criticize the prime
minister's Resolute leadership on
Ukraine but what concerns many of us is
that some of our allies don't seem to be
as Resolute as he that whilst they will
give full support to Ukraine not to lose
this war they're not that Keen on
Ukraine winning this war because they
don't want to accumulate Putin so can
the Prime Minister make clear that it is
the absolute commitment of NATO to
defeat Putin once and for all the
minister I I agree 100 with my uh right
on my friend has said we just with one
clarification which is it is 100 the
objective of uh of of NATO and all our
friends and allies to make sure that
Putin fails in Ukraine and I think it's
very very important that we frame it in
that way um Mr Speaker and and he and he
he can and he will Mr Speaker because
the ukrainians won't have it any other
way very welcome
the UK uh hosted the keeping 1.5 alive
event in Kigali but at the same time the
latest ipcc report said that the
requirement the opportunity to keep
within 1.5 had now shifted forward from
2032 to 2025 given that most major
emitters in the G7 are not actually even
meeting their Paris commitments made
seven years ago what realistic chance
does the Prime Minister believe there is
that the G7 will step up to the plate in
the next three years and Achieve that
turning down of the missions prime
minister I thank him very much and if
you looked at the G7 communique uh he
will have seen there was an explicit
reference to making sure that anything
we did was within our cop 26 commitments
to keeping 1.5 alive and to the uh the
commitments made Under Paris
crispy blood Mr Speaker can I strongly
welcome this statement from the Prime
Minister and say that uh in my time in
the house I can't recall a foreign
Affair statement in which the serving
prime minister could take more personal
satisfaction than the one he has just uh
delivered to the Huts that his
leadership of NATO and uh get getting
the very welcome conclusions of the NATO
Summit
um then only reinforce what the leader
of the opposition said that what Mr
Putin wants is for us to lose focus uh
will he sustain his Focus get the grain
out of Ukraine for the desperate need of
the rest of the world and ensure that
Ukraine's survival as a sovereign state
prime minister
I I thank my road honorable friend very
much and that certainly Remains the
objective of the government but I stress
that this is what we're doing to support
the ukrainians is not just a right in
itself Mr Speaker which everybody
accepts it's also right for the world
and that's why it continues to be
supported around the world
they need awesome
identified that Russia and China
Challenge our security China continues
to make it clear the territories that
their dispute in the indoor Pacific
as War Of Ages in Ukraine concerns for
the West's ammunition stockpiles are
grown and the prime minister is
continuing with plans that will see
capability gaps in our Navy less Plains
less tanks and less troops without a
drastic rethink of these Cuts how
realistic is the UK's desire in the
integrated review to have a presence in
both the North Atlantic and the indoor
Pacific prime minister well actually Mr
Speaker uh What uh our friend if you if
the Commonwealth Summit the most
interesting thing uh was the the
widespread understanding of what the UK
is doing in the indo-pacific Tilt and
the moves we're making to engage with
that part of the world to to strengthen
our friends and allies uh in that region
you saw what uh Mr Speaker what we did
with the carrier strike group absolutely
astonishing exercise and you know about
the orcas uh commitment that we've made
uh Mr Speaker and we're at the embassies
uh in that part of the world and uh and
increasing our deployment Sarah as well
bro General
Mr Speaker let's bring in our chief
political correspondent John Craig who
has been following the prime minister's
statement and the following questions
and answers in the house
um John a lot covered there by the Prime
Minister uh one of the key lines the UK
is likely to raise is defense spending
very considerably in the near future
what else did you pick out of what the
Prime Minister had to say
well it's a statement about three
summits I can't recall a prime minister
doing a statement on three summits at
once perhaps two yes G7 and NATO often
coincide but this one this one has got
the Commonwealth conference as well so
he's talking about the Commonwealth
conference in Rwanda nato in Madrid and
G7 in Bavaria it was noticeable that
even some of his fiercest Critics on the
Tory back benches uh for example Tobias
Elwood and Mark Harper were very
supportive in their uh questions to the
Prime Minister there was real praise
from Tory back benches about the prime
minister's handling of the Ukraine issue
in particular and in fact his handling
of all three summits
um the Prime Minister and his opening
remarks they were absolutely dominated
by Ukraine and the need for uh for a
concerted action and unity amongst the
International Community one thing he
raised was concerns about how some
commonwealth countries had abstained at
the United Nations in motions on Ukraine
but the praise for example from the back
benches included uh sir Edward Lee a few
moments ago talking about all the fluff
he called it about the Prime Minister
the criticism
um was completely overshadowed he
claimed by the praise for the Prime
Minister on the international stage
um now
from the opposition side from Cirque
starmer in particular there was
criticism of the cuts in the armed
forces at the same time as raising
spending on defense uh Sakia with the
shadow defense secretary John Healy
nodding vigorously beside him complained
about the cuts in our armed forces that
was also raised by Ian Blackford the
leader of the SMP at Westminster and
there was also from Sir care a rebuff
for the prime minister's attempts to
dump the Commonwealth uh Secretary
General baroness Scotland former labor
politician of course he said that Mr
Johnson had been humiliated by trying to
get rid of uh baroness Scotland of
course he failed in that one little
PostScript there
um observant viewers will have spotted
just to the on the left of the screen
just now first sight of the new deputy
chief whip Kelly tolhurst taking her
place and alongside the Prime Minister
she of course has just been appointed
the successor to Chris pincher and it
was the first time we'd seen her in that
role she came in and smiled at MPS
around her so as someone who has
benefited from Mr pincher's troubles
yeah her predecessor not mentioned at
all in the house so far John he's
surprised by that MP's clearly thinking
that perhaps now is not the time or the
place to talk about it
well I thought there might be a few
little digs that right at the beginning
of secure stalma's remarks he made a
quite a light-hearted remark about the
Prime Minister coming back to uh
obviously to face his troubles after
eight days away I I thought perhaps the
okay the the odd Troublesome mischievous
back bencher on the labor side or the
SMP might have raised Mr pincher but it
didn't happen plenty of opportunities
later in the week as I mentioned earlier
on Wednesday the prime ministers facing
the liaison committee a two-hour
grilling on issues like Ukraine cost of
living but also ominously for the PM uh
Integrity in politics that's Mr pincher
there on the screen that was just after
he was appointed deputy chief whip in
February and uh that's another occasion
but on that occasion when he was coming
down Whitehall he was pursued by our
colleague Sam Coates and gave some
absolutely fawning glowing uh testimony
and endorsements of the Prime Minister
uh just to showing what a loyal Ally he
was a pro of the PM and uh why a lot of
Tory and Billy P's believe Mr uh Johnson
is fighting to save him not sure he's
going to succeed with that however
let's have a look at some of today's
other news now and Russian forces are
pressing deeper into eastern Ukraine
this is after they capture the last
remaining City in lahansk Ukraine's
military says its soldiers have now
retreated from Melissa chansk but
president zielinski has insisted his
forces will reclaim all of the territory
lost to Russia will Sky correspondent
Sally Lockwood has the latest from Kiev
a significant moment in this war but
certainly not a surprising one it did
look like Lucy chansk was going to fall
as its neighboring City several Donetsk
did last week uh Ukrainian forces really
hanging on in uh fiercely fighting Uh
Russian forces but they made that
decision that tactical decision to
retreat uh yesterday because their
situation in the city was becoming
increasingly precarious uh it looked
like they would soon become completely
surrounded by Russian forces and there
were thousands of Ukrainian soldiers in
the city it could have been an absolute
disaster for them so yes this strategic
decision to withdraw yesterday means
that the entire luhanks region is now in
Russian control which of course makes up
half of the dombas which is that
industrial eastern part of the country
that Russia is determined to take
control of you'll remember just before
the invasion of Ukraine Vladimir Putin
declared that he viewed luhansk and
Donetsk the other region that makes up
the donbass as independent of Ukraine
and Russian proxy forces have been
fighting an Insurgency in the donbass
region since 2014 so a significant
moment that they have now taken control
of the entire luhansk region and we
spoke to the governor of luhansk a
little earlier to ask the latest from
him he said that he's already been
contacted by Russia to see if he would
collaborate presumably to form some sort
of proxy government he's rejected any
sort of offer Fern said he's cut
communication and I asked him what the
conditions were for civilians still in
the region
civilians have a huge problem with
critical infrastructure because the
Russians have completely destroyed
everything in just a few months that is
there is no Central gas water or
electricity Supply this is a huge
problem and the Russians are looking for
anyone who supports the Ukrainian
government taking them to an unknown
location destroying Ukrainian books
everything that is Ukrainian is being
destroyed
certainly a great deal of concern for
those civilians who remain in the
luhansk region there's still a
significant number of the many many in
the hardest hit areas have been
Sheltering in bunkers for weeks and
weeks now without power without water
without any ability to communicate with
their families elsewhere so a great deal
of concern about what may happen to them
but the governor of luhansk also said
that he's far more optimistic about how
the donetsk's region May Fair of course
that other region in the donbass which
is still largely in Ukrainian control
because they've had far longer to
prepare their defense lines and
fortifications there it's also a larger
area he thinks that it's going to be a
much tougher fight for the Russians in
donets but they've already turned their
site to that other region just yesterday
one of the main cities there slobbyans
was heavily shelled by Russia six people
lost their lives there
including a child so yes a significant
moment in this war so far but still a
long way to go the fighting in the
donbath is far from over uh the big
question now is whether Ukraine can
defend itself in donets and stop this
Russian advance and whether Russia can
maintain this momentum
or more analysis now from a former
British Army intelligence officer and
chief executive of McKenzie intelligence
forms McKenzie Forbes welcome back and
let's talk about the final City in El
Hans reason region to fall into Russian
hands this is a chance Ukraine forces
gone now where have they gone and where
do they think Russia's next Target will
be that's right so over the weekend
um the ukrainians quietly left this a
chance kind of kind of assessed to have
moved to a line between slovians and
back commitment as the E40 is the kind
of Main Road and those have been
fighting have had a tough time of it of
recent weeks and months they've gone
into a phase of rest recuperation and
they'll be pre-prepared positions that
are defensive in nature this looks like
to be a relatively successful withdrawal
which takes us to the kind of next phase
of operations
um the Russians have also had a
particularly tough time of it as we've
seen this is hard fought land they also
need to go into a feast of of rest
recuperations and in the medium term
we'll see
um activity there'll be probing attacks
when slovianskin and and Bachman and
then in the long term and we've heard
Putin talk today about the the offense
must keep going on so certainly his eye
his eyes are now firmly on the rest of
the donbass region so there's a bit of
regrouping going on on both sides at the
moment Forbes um president zielinski
striking a positive note saying look you
know we are going to get back all of the
land and we have lost to Russia and he's
saying that's because of the weapons
they will have at their disposal why in
particular is he talking about the
weapon systems that we're starting to
see come into the um the theater of
operations uh the French uh Caesar one
of 155 Heritage systems are getting
brought in and the American himarsis
Himmler system and over the weekend that
was used effectively against a number of
targets um airfields held by Russians
this is a Japanese example that we see
here very very effective 50 mile radius
and six missiles can be launched at any
one time 16 seconds get brought into
combat which is really really fast and
highly accurate as well okay Forbes
thank you Forbes McKenzie there right
we're going to take a quick break before
we do that we're going to take a check
on the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it's going to turn warmer and drier but
it will be rather great and damp for
many of us tomorrow wet in the Northwest
later before then it's going to be
mostly dry and quite Sunny to end this
afternoon but Northern Western Scotland
expect some showers the northwest of
Ireland will see cloud and patchy light
rain Island Northern Ireland are parts
of central Britain will see Misty low
Cloud patchy light rain and drizzle
taking over tonight while the far north
may keep the odd shower it's going to be
mostly dry and clear elsewhere Southern
Britain Island and Northern Ireland will
be rather gray and damp tomorrow morning
after a fine start in the South Northern
Britain will be mostly dry and sunny
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you're watching Sky News after the break
residents of Bedford told to keep their
windows and doors closed this is after a
huge gas explosion in a block of flats
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
spaces across the city so our main kind
of driving force is to get people
growing
foreign